a fishing trip on Vancouver Island  turned into the experience of a lifetime  after a rare encounter with an octopus  wow look at it a northern giant Pacific  octopus was found clinging onto a crab  trap filled with prawns I bet Brook's  satter was left in disbelief the Port  Alberni resident says it happened last  week on the Alberni Inlet  when we first started pulling the Trap  up it was super heavy so we just thought  it was a pretty full prawn trap and it  was orange just like prawns so we're  like wow this trap is like so full and  then as it was like surfacing we're like  oh my gosh that is a huge octopus I was  just like super excited to actually see  it I love  um ocean life so  I was very like excited and surprised  Brooke's video posted to social media  has received around 30 million views she  says she's grateful she got to share her  rare encounter with the world